for our daily cancellation today we must
discuss a story that
in another time and another place you
would assume is parody it starts with a
man named kelly donohue
a contestant on the now tribecas
jeopardy uh donahue on tuesday
appeared on the game show after his
third win
while being introduced by the host he
briefly flashed three fingers to the
camera you could see it
three fingers um signifying that he'd
won three times we know that this is the
meaning behind the three fingers because
the day before he had flashed two
fingers and before that one
now i'm no math ways but i'm starting to
sense maybe a pattern here
now if you're a normal person a
well-adjusted person you might see the
three fingers
not understand the context and not do
any research into the issue because it
doesn't matter
such a person the normal well-adjusted
type if you see someone hold up three
fingers
and doesn't know why we'll think oh well
i guess there's some banal reason why
he's holding him three fingers
hmm okay well i guess i'll just continue
on living my life now
but the problem of course is that we
live in a country overrun by people who
are not normal or well-adjusted many
people sadly
are emotionally stunted lunatics with
the iqs of doorknobs
and so the fact that a guy on jeopardy
held up three fingers became
a problem a controversy a source of
outrage
it was decided by the doorknob clan that
kelly's three-finger salute was actually
a secret message
to his fellow white supremacists kelly
donahue
may seem like a mild-mannered jeopardy
contestant but beneath that facade he's
a skinhead and a terrorist
and we know this because he moved his
singer fingers in a certain way
that's what the mob decided as the
controversy grew a post appeared on
medium
purportedly from a group of former
jeopardy contestants almost
almost 600 former contestants apparently
signed this letter
denouncing kelly donahue for holding up
three fingers
again i'm not making this up this is not
a parody
this is real this is a lengthy letter
posted apparently signed by 600 people
condemning someone for arranging their
fingers in a certain way
the letter first condemned donahue for
apparently saying the word gypsy
on monday so the day before the
three-finger um
uh assault he said the word gypsy in
response to a clue
um the word gypsy is now offensive
apparently
i'm not sure what else you're supposed
to call gypsies i also don't care but
the gypsy kerfuffle was not the biggest
problem as the letter says reading now
says quote tuesday april 27th was a more
widely felt misstep
during his on-camera introduction kelly
made a gesture with his hand
that he has since claimed was an
indication that he had won three games
he had on previous episodes indicated
with one finger and two fingers
that he had won one in two games and no
reasonable person would have interpreted
those
gestures differently however this
gesture was not a clear-cut symbol for
the number three
he held his thumb and forefinger
together with his other three fingers
extended and palm facing inward and he
tapped his chest
this whether intentional or not
resembled very closely a gesture that
has been co-opted by
white power groups alt-right groups and
an anti-government group
that calls itself the three percenters
in a public facebook post that has since
been deleted kelly states
that's a number three no more no less
his public facebook profile also
features a cover photo of frank sinatra
making a similar gesture
this was either erased or made private
on wednesday morning along with hundreds
of public comments on his few jeopardy
related posts
regardless of his stated intent the
gesture is a racist dog whistle
some of the first people to notice this
were not affiliated with jeopardy in any
way they were viewers who couldn't
believe what they'd seen
captured it on video and shared it on
twitter among them were people of color
who needless to say
are attuned to racist messaging and not
appreciative that the show allowed this
symbol to be broadcast
oh but wait it gets dumber continuing
most problematic to us uh as a conte as
a contestant community is the fact that
kelly has not publicly apologized for
the ramifications of the gesture he made
if something has been misconstrued an
apology and a total disavowal of any
connection to white supremacist
doctrines
is called for oh my gosh
um we saw that gesture we saw that
gesture air on television
we are among the public it affected
and we are a diverse group of people
people of color
religious minorities and other
marginalized marginalized groups
already live in the united states in a
canada that have structural
institutional racism sexism
anti-semitism ableism homophobia and
transphobia
embedded into their history and function
these people deal with microaggressions
nearly every day of their lives
through words actions and assumptions
that remind them on a constant basis
that they are not the default they are
not the mainstream they are not real
citizens
and that is hard enough that is enough
for them to bear and enough for us to
keep trying to recognize to address and
to fight that is already a series of
walls and fences
that keeps us from from truly reaching
the american ideal
of e pluribus unum we cannot stand up
for hate
we cannot stand next to hate by the way
this is all still about the fingers okay
we cannot stand on stage with something
that looks like hate
we are ashamed to be associated with
brands and identities that suffer
the taint of hateful statements and
actions particularly if they go
unchallenged by those at the top
all right it's hard to know where to
begin
in dissecting this abject
madness in encountering the leftist
mindset i feel much as i feel when
walking into one of my kids rooms and
seeing the chaos of toys and debris
strewn all over the place i i don't know
where to begin
in cleaning it up fortunately i don't
have to i tell them to do it it's their
room knowing full well that they're just
going to stuff everything under the bed
i haven't i have a don't ask don't tell
policy on those sorts of things
just get the mess out of my site i don't
care where it goes
mommy feels differently you know that if
she's telling you but for me just
i don't want to see it any case
back on subject um in trying to sort
through the mess of leftist psychosis on
display here i suppose we could start
with the fact that
the three-finger symbol is not a white
power symbol and never was
the left simply decided at some point
that it is or should be
and announced that heretofore if you
around if you arrange your fingers in
that way
you're a racist whether you meant to be
or not
and we could also note the truly
diabolical lunacy inherent in the idea
that intent doesn't matter the outraged
members of the contestant community
the newest marginalized group on display
on on the scene here maybe they'll get
added to the lgbt acronym
you know lgbtqia
cc for contested community but they say
that uh even if he didn't mean to flash
a white power sign he should still
apologize
for their misinterpretation
of course the truth is exactly the
opposite
if you wildly misconstrue someone else's
meaning and intent
and accuse them of saying something they
didn't say
it's you who should apologize you're at
fault
i don't have to apologize to you for
your false accusations against me
we might also mention the incr the in
you know incredible fragility
demonstrated here we hear so much about
white fragility but what can we say
about a person who feels traumatized and
attacked
by the number three
and how do these people ever watch
sesame street
today's number is number three they go
screaming out of the rooms hide under
the bed
make it stop what is there to be said
about people who are suffering ptsd
because of the way a jeopardy contestant
positioned his fingers this is a
maniacal level of fragility
these are people who in saner times
would be committed to asylums
i'm not even kidding these are people
who should be in lunatic asylums
they are psychotic
now these are all things that we might
say if we wanted to defend kelly donahue
from these outrageous attacks
but i have a policy that i've told you
before about defending people from the
cancel mob i only defend
those who are willing to defend
themselves and there's a reason for that
i can't defend you if you're going to
kneecap me in mid defense by apologizing
for doing the very thing
that i was just defending and so i can't
defend donahue sadly
i can't defend him because of this which
he posted to his facebook yesterday
here's what he said
i'm truly horrified with what what has
been posted about me on social media
i absolutely unequivocally condemn white
supremacy and racism of any kind
people who know me personally know that
i'm not a racist but for the public at
large it bears repeating i am not a
racist and i reject and condemn white
supremacy in all forms of bigotry for
the evil they are
it's shameful to me to think anyone
would try to use the stage of jeopardy
to
advance or promote such a disgusting
agenda during the taping of my fourth
episode i was simply raising three
fingers to mark my third win
there was nothing more i was trying to
indicate i deeply regret
this terrible misunderstanding i never
meant to hurt a soul and i assure you
i am no friend of racist and white
supremacist i removed the previous post
because the comments were more than i
could bear
i stand by the statements itself and you
could find it reported in other media i
did however understand the fair
criticism
that i didn't include a forceful
condemnation of white supremacy
in my initial statement i hope my
feelings on that matter are clear now
okay well kelly
you're on your own bud with that you're
on your own
not gonna get a defense not gonna get
any sympathy
because i am tired of this i'm tired of
it
i know it can be overwhelming when
you've got thousands of people coming
after you accusing you of being racist
saying all things these things that
aren't true happens to me a lot
but but we we need to require of each
other
a little bit of a spine just a little
bit not asking for much
apologizing and and barking on command
like a
dog because these scumbags told you to
condemning white supremacy like there's
any reason for you to do it
as if there was ever any indication at
all that you're a white supremacist
no now i you know now i i lump you in
with them
now i feel the same way about you as i
do about the rest of them i do
now here's the thing when you when you
apologize
for something you admit guilt
now you're not guilty obviously all you
did was hold up three fingers
but you've admitted guilt for something
you didn't do
because you can't apologize for
something you can't actually apologize
for something that you didn't do
right the apology doesn't mean anything
it's like if someone you know if bob
comes up to you and tells you that
jim just punched him in the face
are you gonna say uh oh i apologize for
that
what do you you didn't do it what are
you apologizing for
or better yet because in this case
nothing happened at all it's better if
someone if someone comes
up to you and says that um you know and
and accuses you
of sending your invisible dragon over to
their house
to uh burn it down and you say oh
oh i apologize for that no you didn't do
it
so by apologizing you're admit it
you can't in order to apologize you must
admit guilt it comes with the territory
inherent in the apology is an admission
of guilt
and that's why it becomes impossible to
defend you you said you were guilty
basically
now the appropriate response to this
kelly is to say
to the people accusing you of this f you
uh i apologize for nothing you people
owe an apology to me
you lunatics and by the way i'm gonna
sue you
for defamation i need all of you
personally to apologize
to me publicly and beg for my
forgiveness
or i will not stop until i bankrupted
you all in court
that's what the response should have
been but it wasn't
so kelly donahue was canceled all the
people trying to cancel him are
cancelled
and again we end the week with a with a
round a round of cancellation for
everyone
which is always a fun way to end it if
you enjoyed this video be sure to give
it a thumbs up and share it with all
your friends